the Joe Rogan experience I'll tell you I
I think a couple things come up and just
kind of fun what you're what you're
saying and this is kind of my
perspective on it when you know when we
talk about hey when you go in somewhere
you've got to know what the end state is
you got to know what you're you know you
got to know where you're going and when
you're gonna leave gotta have an exit
strategy what's really hard about that
is we don't necessarily know and war is
so and predict unpredictable that you
may you know there's there's a chance
that you went in and killed Qaddafi and
then all of a sudden some benevolent
person steps up and all of a sudden
you've got this flourishing democracy
okay with the chance to that no very
small but you don't know that it's gonna
go into this this completely failed
state you have high hopes maybe your
Intel people are saying you this it's
like when we you know when we did the
Bay of Pigs all the Cubans in America
were like yep as soon as you guys hit
the beaches all the Cubans are gonna be
on our side it's gonna be good to go all
the Cubans that supported America were
in America we showed up there and they
were like what are you doing no this is
our country so we don't necessarily know
where we're gonna go which means you've
got to have once again like the open
mind to say oh this isn't going the way
we thought it was going to go how we
going to adjust right now to prevent
this from getting worse which means what
you really have to do is prior to
intervening in other countries you have
to assess what sacrifices you are
willing to make to to get the result
that is positive and yeah and it's and
those those could be massive you know I
always talk about if you're gonna go to
war you've got to have the will and that
will comes in two forms number one is
the will to kill because when you go to
war you are going to be killing people
you're going to be killing the enemy and
you're gonna be killing civilians and
now that's that's not what we're trying
to do and believe me the US military
goes through great lengths to prevent
that from happening
but it is gonna happen it's war so you
have to be willing to kill you have to
be willing to have that happen and you
have to be willing to die because when
you go to war there's gonna be American
kids that are not going to come home and
so you have to have those two wills
that's before you go in so you can't
look at it and say well you know we can
go into Libya we can move this guy and
probably it'll turn out okay so we don't
have to worry about what the sacrifices
are gonna be another thing to think
about when we went to war when you went
to world war two World War one those
kids 18 years old 17 years old those
kids went to war until the war was over
they were they went on deployment like
now you know in the in the Navy in the
Marine Corps up to six seven-month
deployment and the army sometimes it's a
14-month appointment and then they're
gonna rotate back to the states in World
War two it's like oh cool yeah we're at
war you'll be home when it's over so
five years four years if that was our
attitude going into the war this is so
important to us that johnny is gonna get
on a ship and he's gonna sail to the
Pacific and if he comes home it's gonna
be in three years four years five years
that's what we're talking about that's
the level of commitment we have so when
we start looking at going into other
countries we need to start thinking okay
what level of commitment do we really
have to make this successful and and
like even when I look at Iraq you know I
was in Iraq and fought in Iraq from a
granular perspective being on the ground
Battle of Ramadi 2006 the citizens of
Ramadi the normal citizens of Ramadi
were overjoyed that we were there and it
was like we were we were angels to go
there and help them get rid of these
heinous al Qaeda insurgents which
eventually came became Isis
unfortunately you know we kind of we we
did a great job Ramadi was the model of
counterinsurgency for about seven years
and it was less violent than many cities
in America and I had great pride and at
least understood the sacrifices my
friends that were killed my friends that
never came home my friends that won't
get to have kids right they did all that
they gave all that and I was able to
look around and say you know what these
folks in this foreign country they're
gonna have an opportunity for freedom
and unfortunately because of politics
and whatever we said okay you know what
we're we're not staying there we're
gonna leave
as soon as we left everybody they'd been
on the ground in Iraq was like mm-hmm
this is probably not a good idea this is
probably not a good idea to bail out
right now we don't need to leave a
massive force there but you know if we
leave a few you know we leave a couple
brigades worth of men then Oh we'll
probably be able to handle any problems
that that happen
well we didn't we left completely and
and those those insurgents that were
there they were like little embers and
they started to they started to get
fired up again and then the next thing
you know you had Isis and by the way
Isis marched back into Ramadi and they
the reports we got from people on the
ground that we knew was that Isis came
in and anyone that had worked with
coalition forces in any level they would
murder the whole families about five
hundred families that were completely
murdered so when we talk about these
things we have to be very sure about
what we're gonna do we have to recognize
that we can't predict everything because
we can't I don't care how good you are
and care how many analysis you put on
something when you start throwing human
nature into a leadership vacuum all
these things are gonna break out and
it's gonna it can go very very bad it
can go well too but it can go very very
bad and so what are we willing to
sacrifice what are we willing to spend
how many of our brothers and sisters in
uniform are we willing to sacrifice to
make this happen and how does it help
our national security I believe right
now had we stayed there Iraq would be a
pretty strong positive place right now
if we had kind of completed the mission
the way that we should have again when
we go back and we say okay well what
what what countries is it worth going
into you know where are we gonna go what
how do we draw that line how do we make
that decision for me this is this is
what we do as leaders what we do as
leaders we look at a situation and and
sometimes you know you can ask yourself
do we have a moral obligation to go
somewhere if there's a genocide
happening if there's another Rwanda
happening where 800,000 Tutsis are
killed in hundred days with machetes if
that's going on do we have a moral
obligation to try and do something to
help that hey that's a decision you have
to meet that's a hard decision to make
as leader because guess what you're
gonna lose 30 40 100 Americans that are
going in there and try
shut this thing down but that's the
that's the type of thing we need to
think about and that's why as a leader
you want to have an open mind you want
to have your ego completely out of it
because it's real easy to say oh this is
where America this is what we do this is
we're gonna win it's like no actually we
made a bad decision and we're actually
leaving right now because we think the
expenditure from here on out is gonna be
too hot unfortunate I think in Iraq we
paid the upfront expenditure we had
invested lives and treasure to try and
get that play stabilized we had done a
decent job we were almost there and we
left early and all of a sudden we look
around to go but that's why these things
are important too to think about
thoroughly as Tulsi said before you go
we don't know what's going to happen and
you know if you're gonna get in a street
fight Joe like you look as capable as
you are as capable as I am at street
fighting that's great there is that 10
percent chance that that guy pulls out a
knife and sticks it in your neck and are
you willing to sacrifice that now if the
guy's doing something to an innocent
person and you go you know what I got to
take that risk right now I'm gonna go in
and I'm gonna I'm gonna get this thing
handled those are hard decisions to make
and we have to think through them
[Applause]